jean paul ii s'est donc posé sur le sol
français à 10h30 à l'aéroport d'orly
alain de chalvron le correspondant de
france 2 à rome qui suit tous les
déplacements du souverain pontife était
dans l'avion avec le pape
pour ce septième voyage en france à son
arrivée ce matin à 8 heures à l'aéroport
de rome jean paul ii paraissait très
concentré un peu fatigué c'est dans sa
cale indifférent aux applaudissements
mais dans l'avion le pape retrouvera
vite le sourire et prendra le soin de
saluer tous les membres de sa délégation
y compris bien sûr son médecin personnel
le docteur boyzone est il que l'on voit
ici et il ne le quittera plus d'une
seconde pendant tout le voyage afin de
rassurer tout le monde jean paul ii
s'est enfin rendu auprès des
journalistes anxieux de savoir comment
il se sentait comme nous voyons en effet
le pape se sont jeunes mais ne l'est
plus vraiment fatigué oui certes
je le sens très concentré e
j'aurais vu cette dernière encore à 4
euros c'est un pape qui le passe si l'on
peut dire que pato
abdou sli pas au pape
pour lui c'est quatre journées qui
passera par ici sont des journées qui
sont comme le résumé de
de tout son projet
des vents chauds il est en forme il
fallait sonne plus lente mois il a fait
tout sur moi qui bâtit un voisin le
problème c'est que dans le programme
prévu pour ces jmj
il n'est guère prévu justement d'aller
vraiment